Hi everyone. In this lesson, we're going to take a look at foliage optimization when it
comes to some material control, as well as foliage optimization when it comes to using
world partition. So let's get started. So you can edit the material as well as looking
at the end call distance in the parameter for the foliage. And you can combine these
in such a way we can actually control how they show up in your scene. Now this is catering
a bit more towards interactive experiences and final pixel because you're controlling
what the material does as well as that call distance. So when you do this, this can be
reduced by adding a start call distance parameter inside that material and then setting up the
material appropriately for it. To be able to do this, we would actually create a per
instance fade amount note. So when connecting that to an opacity or masking value, you
can use it to fade instances over a distance before they reach the call distance end and
are removed from rendering. Now again, you have to be careful with this because you may
get a little bit of noise when you use it. So just use it wisely if you were to try it
out. I'm going to demonstrate a little bit how it's set up in the material in just a
second. But we also want to look at here that you can control this setting overall.
And it is a bit more game centric. And there's a couple ways. So if we look at the previous
slide, you'll see here we have a texture sample. This is in kind of its more simplest form.
A per instance fade amount controlled here, a multiply and then a general constant that
you can actually adjust the numbers. You'll see it eventually goes into another multiply,
which has the information for that object. And then it goes into the opacity mask. If
we go to the next slide, you'll see here that there's a there's a switch parameter in place.
And in that switch parameter, you can control the inputs. And from there, you can actually
have it. So every aspect of this material is being pulled through with that opacity mask
to be able to pop in the material when needed. You'll see the per distance fade amount, a
dither temporal a a and then a multiply. Let's go and take a peek at it in an unreal.
So as we see in unreal, I have a material called m a read this particular material is using
all of the reads in our scene. So if you do want to check and you are doing this just
a quick pro tip, we can go in here and click on finding where that materials at, you can
right click. And then you can go in here under asset actions, go in here and say select actor
using this asset. So we can see like, all of our let's get out of foliage mode for that
to work correctly. We can see that all of our assets are being used by it. So if I click
on that magnifying glass, right click on it, and then go to asset actions, select actors
using this asset, you'll see that all of them are being selected. So we know that's we're
in the right spot. So in here, what I have here is the per instance fade amount. I'm
using this input data to be able to actually control here our alpha threshold results here
for our dither temporal AA. Now you can make it random coming from our scene here where
we have two different material attributes. And in here we have the different types of
setup. There's somewhat similar, but a little bit different in the fact that one on the
top is a bit more complex. And the one on the bottom has also its own dependencies.
So they are a little bit different. And this is just the way the nature of how this was
made. So taking into account the normal is the roughness of specular. And you'll also
see this normal rough specular opacity mask. These dependencies are in here. And what we're
doing is we're doing a true and false here switch parameter. So if we ever wanted to
turn these on or off, we can in an instance material. So what we're doing here then is
we're grabbing the multiply and we're bringing it right into that opacity mask. Now you can
choose to turn this on and off to see what visual results you get using an instance material.
And this particular case, I'm just going to show you what we have. And I'm going to go
ahead and hit apply. And I'm going to show you how you can adjust some of the properties
and how the coal within the foliage tool can help and work with this particular offset.
So now let's go ahead and I'm going to move this off to the side. And we're going to go
back into the foliage tool with the foliage tool active, I'm going to make sure that all
the ones that are using that particular shader are all on with them all on. And I'm just
going to select them all, we're going to go ahead and be able to control the coal all
at one time. So we're going to scroll down to our coal volume and our coal volume in
the first slot, whatever number you punch in here will go automatically to the max.
But what we can do is type in like maybe 500 or 200 in the max here and then over here
in the minimum, we can go ahead and put like 100. Now as I move around, you'll see it smoothly
pop in and out in our scene specifically the outdoor indoor. And actually let's hit apply
for our material to make sure it is applied. There you go. So it's good. And you'll notice
if you look really good, ignore my circular, circular painting little icon here, but you'll
see the foliage start to come in and out of scene. There you go. You can see it kind of go away.
And it's actually not too bad. Get it kind of nicely fades in. And the shader is helping a
little bit here. But is the shader an end all beyond? Is it actually something you initially
have to use? No, but it is another option, especially for virtual production, and maybe even
final pixel, but it's really geared more towards games. But this allows you to control the fade
distance within this object. Depending on your dependencies that you want to punch in, you
can either make it have it random like we talked about, or you can make it so that you control
it yourself by pulling in a scalar parameter, if you will. We can also use a thing called a coal
volume. Now, I don't typically use these because they are pretty old school and they work okay.
There is a tendency if you're not careful with your numbers, you will get some popping going on.
It might be better to use that material option that I told you about and use the coal distance
based inside of the tool itself of painting foliage. But you do have the ability to actually
create one and put them in place. Let me point you where they're at. But I'll let you play with it
and decide if you feel this may fit your needs. Now, again, this is catering more towards
interactivity as well as final pixel, but not so much ICV effects. I would probably stay away
from it because it can turn out looking pretty fake if you're not careful, especially if your
camera is aggressive or moves a little bit faster than needed. But that's mostly on a more linear
direction going forward and going backward, which rarely does happen in ICV effects. A lot of times
your camera is going to move mainly side to side to give the illusion and not give up the
reality that you are on a volume. To simply get to it and put it in place, let's go and close
the Foldage tool for a moment. I'm going to go in here and go to selection here for a second.
In my selection mode, I'm going to go in here and simply I can just type in volume if I want to or
just type in call. Or you can do the same thing here on the top down here by just clicking in the
space, get content and start typing. So there's my cold distance volume. I can pull him into space
and then now that he is in place, let's go and grab him because he went took off into another land.
That cold distance volume, we're going to actually make it so that we can space out exactly what
areas we want him to be in. I'm going to hit the F key to find out where he's at. There he goes,
just off camera. So I'm going to pull him down a little bit, pull him into here. And again,
these values are up to you. You can make them extreme. If for some reason you have a lot of
stuff and you don't need to get to those areas just yet, that may be a case where you may be using it
with ICB effects, or there may be a case where you're interactively, you want to be able to control
how much is on your screen at one particular time. So we'll push this into the ground
and simply control its environment here and what you want it to do. Now, again, each one of these
is based on your needs. So there's never a one size fits all. And you want to make it encased
as far as you want that reaction to happen. So it's basically like you wouldn't use any volume,
except for post process where you can actually make an infinite extent of bound. In this particular
case, you kind of want to control exactly when things come in. You'll see that we have it enabled
right now. And you'll see there's some advanced settings, which allow you to align a brush vertices
if you want to do a little bit of editing on a brush level. But up above here, we can see that
we have cold distance control, we have an index, we can choose that size if we want to, and we can
add different volumes if we want to, or I should say distance control. So each one's going to be a
bit different. It's up to you. Now you would change that size. And then you would change the cold
distance based on your needs. Now you want to do it in descending order if you can, making it so that
it is drawn appropriately based on where your camera's at versus where you're positioning
this particular call and when you want things to show up into the party. All right, cool. Let's go
back into our slides. And you see some suggested numbers I give you here that you can experiment
with. You'll see the size 10, 200. And again, we're increasing our distance here. And you can
choose how you want things to go. We have a 50 and a 500, besides 200, we could easily set this a
little bit higher to like 1000. And you can experiment with it by sending some of these two lower
numbers to see how it changes in transitions. And you'll notice there may be a little bit of popping
when working with it. You now can also control the density of the foliage being rendered during
runtime with the command foliage density scale. Below you can see the density of the foliage change
as a foliage density density scale setting is set to 0.1 and 1.0. So let's take a look at some
material limitations that can occur. So distance fields for mass materials are generated for the
visible part of the material. So mass materials create significant overdraw. So you got to keep
that in mind, especially when we're working with lumen. So for foliage, an example, an instance
painted using the foliage mode, like you're dragging it in per se, to affect lumen, it must be nanite.
So go into that object. If you're going to paint it, you need to actually go into that physical
object and make sure one that it's nanite. And we also need to make sure the distance field
lights and visible ray tracing are enabled. So let's go ahead and do that. And you want to do that in
that asset itself. So I just drug the asset in here so I can go in here and go distance field
effects, this and field lighting bingo ray tracing. So you want to make sure it's visible and ray
tracing. So these are really important, especially if you're grabbing stuff from the marketplace,
you want to double check these. Some of these may be already on, but you do want to triple check
whenever, especially if you did not originally make this asset. So also we need to make sure it's
nanite. So let me click this out for a second, find where this guy is at, and then right click
and double check just as easy as we talked about the other classes, turn on nanite. This is going
to be your best steps to be able to make sure this is drawn efficiently and that we can paint on this
object and bring it into our foliage tool and work with it there. So let's take a brief look at world
partition. So in world partition in your map, the default grid size for foliage instances is 256,
256 meters. This is separate from the world partition grid size. So to change the default
size of the instance foliage grid for the new maps, you want to go into your project settings
to simply type in foliage, and then you can set the grid size, which you need, so that things are
being filled out accordingly. Now you want to open those project settings by opening the edit menu
and select project settings in the search box. Like I said, you want to do foliage, then you want to
change that instance foliage grid size value to your desired value in centimeters. And this is
really depends on the size of your world, and it's a bit more on the virtual production and
final pixel side. But you would change that. You'll see an example, we have 25,600 centimeters is equal
to 256 meters. So you kind of have to do the math there and be able to figure out where and how you
want that foliage equally represented in your scene. Now again, the default grid size can be
changed for existing maps using the world partition builder command let. Now keep in mind, in the case
of ICVFX, you probably won't be using world partition, because it's a little bit more of open
world, a little bit more gamey, a little bit more final pixel and virtual production. But to be able
to actually expand on some of these, you'll see, I'm giving you some information here. So in
Windows, we can open a command prompt window at the prompt begin by navigating to the location
of the Unreal editor dot exe executable file. And in the above example, you'll see, or I should say
off to the right, your builds home on real five engine engine binaries when 64. Next, you want to
begin the command with the name of the exe file that will run the command let unreal editor dot
exe. And you're going to add the name of the project. That's where you're going to put it and
add the name of the target map where you're going to your focus area. Now finish the command with
the name of the command let and the following arguments. So again, we have run world partition
builder command let is the name of the command. Builder equals world partition foliage builder
is the name of the builder within the command let. And then we have grid size is the new value of
the instance foliage grid size and centimeters. An example again, the value is five, five thousand
one or 51,000, I should say 200 is equal to 512 meters. This is why you do art. I don't do math.
That's it with this lecture. Feel free to click on the link that I've provided to dive deeper into
some of the things when it comes to foliage. In the next video, we're going to take a look at
Niagara optimization as a whole. Thanks again.